Tom Felton is the actor that played
Draco Malfoy right you [__] with Tom
Felton yeah I do Tom felt on these nuts
so I guess like Tom Felton is a pretty I
don't know like looked up to guy he's a
musician he played Draco Malfoy he's a
good actor so this dude basically has
this lawyer like draft up a contract
that says I'm your best friend if you
sign this okay and like these are the
stipulations like once signed these are
the things you have to do it's like once
a year you have to wish me happy
birthday and all these things I found
out where Tom was gonna be yeah like
this like charity golf tournament and he
like got himself submitted and he
printed the contract on a T-shirt and
like bumped into him and asked him to
sign his shirt like wore the shirt
underneath his golf oh I think I've seen
this and it bumped into him and be like
hey could you sign my shirt yeah and Tom
was like sure yeah I signed the shirt
and then he took it home and was like
all that's required is for me to sign
the other side and we're officially best
friend like god dude
oh my God